COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERED
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING EVER
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS. TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN
CAPITAL ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
WITH NONE OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
IN ROOMFORTY TWO OH THREE WITH
ME OUR SENATORS CORTESE DOLLY
GLAZER MCGUIRE OF TROUBLES AND
PAN TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS
WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
pTELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S FOR NUMBER IS
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE.
SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN THREE SIX.
TWO EIGHT THREE TWO FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL
BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION. PURPOSES ONLY
ONE TIME PLEASE WAIT PATIENTLY
FOR AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE. THERE CAN BE A SHORT WAIT
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN QUEUE FOR
THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU WILL
BE I NEEDED AND YOU ARE NOW
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING ON. OF WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE ARE HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER. AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
JUST INTO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE
TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO
ALL. INTERESTED PARTIES MAY BE
HEARD. WE HAVE A BILL ON AGENDA.
BILLS ARE ON CONSENT THE BILL
SIGNED CONSENT OUR ITEM THREE
SB FOUR FIFTY THREE. ITEM FOR
SB FIVE FORTY SEVEN. ITEM SIX
SB SEVEN OH ONE. ITEM EIGHT SB
SEVEN TWENTY THREE. BEFORE WE
HEAR OUR PRESENTATION OF BILLS
ESTABLISH A QUORUM MEDIC
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. LEYVA HERE THEY WERE HERE
PHOTO ABOVE HERE THE TROUBLE
CARE CORTESE YOUR ATTENTION
HERE DAILY HERE KELLY HERE
GLAZER. GLAZER HERE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE HERE PAN. THANK YOU A
QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE UP
THE CONSENT CALENDAR DO WE HAVE
A MOTION SIR IT'S SUMMER BY
SENATOR GLAZERS AND CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
ROLE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
LEYVA HI I OF CHAU A BUG. OTOBO
GOODBYE CURTIS. COURTESY I
VALLEY ON DELHI AYE AYE GLAZER
I'D- MCGUIRE AYE PAN. THANK YOU
MADAM CONSULTANT OKAY LET'S
HEAR FROM OUR FIRST AUTHOR
WELCOME SENATOR PORTANTINO
PLEASE LET US KNOW ABOUT SB
THREE TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. IT'S
GREAT TO BE HERE THIS MORNING-
HERE TO PRESENT SB THREE TWENTY
EIGHT WHICH IS A CLEAN UP BILL
FOR THE PREVIOUS SCHOOL START
TIME MEASURE FIRST I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF. AND SENATOR MCGUIRE AS
WELL FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE
ON THIS BILL I'M GOING TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
IN COMMENT FIVE ON PAGE SIX TO
REFLECT THE CAP OF 20% ON THE
AMOUNT OF AFTER SCHOOL FUNDING
LOCAL DISTRICTS CAN CHOOSE TO
USE BEFORE SCHOOL PROGRAMMING-
WITH SCHOOL TO START TIMES
BEGINNING LATER IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT SCHOOLS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO USE SOME OF THE
FUNDING BEFORE SCHOOL IF THEY
NEED TO WHILE ENSURING THAT
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS REMAIN
INTACT THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT
SAYS CAME OUT OF A TOWN HALL
WITH SENATOR RUBIO SEVERAL OF
HER SUPERINTENDENT'S THE
REQUESTED SOME FLEXIBILITY
GIVEN THAT THE AFTERNOON TIME
WOULD BE SHORTER THEY WANT TO
HAVE SOME OPPORTUNITY TO USE
SOME OF THE FUNDS IN THE
MORNING I THINK. THE TWENTY
PERCENT- RESTRICTION- HITS THE
SWEET SPOT SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT SB THREE TWENTY EIGHT ALSO
AUTHORIZES A SCHOOL DISTRICT
SUBJECT TO A START TIME
REQUIREMENTS TOP FOR SURF CLUB
SURF CLASS WORKLOAD BEFORE THE
START OF SCHOOL DAY I KNOW THAT
WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS
IMPORTANT. TO THE CHAIR THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE WHEN WE WENT
THROUGH WITH THE FIRST BILL SO
WE'RE WE'RE GONNA TRY TO
ACCOMMODATE THAT AS WELL IT
ALSO WOULD PROHIBIT A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FROM IMPOSING ANY
RULE REGULATION ORDINANCE OR
CONDITION THAT WOULD PROHIBIT
AN ALLEY A FROM OMPLYING WITH
STATE LAW. WHICH IS ALSO
IMPORTANT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT DISTRICTS HAVE THE ABILITY
TO MEET THE DEMANDS ™THIS
LEGISLATION AND I ALSO WANT TO
THANK SENATOR MCGUIRE WHO I'VE
BEEN IN DISCUSSION ON THE
DISSECTIONS OF THE BILL- WHICH
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE AS IT
MOVES TO HIS COMMITTEE. AND
REGARDS TO- THAT. SECTION AS
WELL- LASTLY SB THREE TO EIGHT
OF ZERO SCHOOL THE- FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AN EXEMPTION.
CONTAINED IN FROM THE ORIGINAL
BILL UNDER THIS BILL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. AND CHARTER SCHOOLS
WOULD QUALIFY FOR THE RURAL
EXEMPTIONOF ONE OF THREE
QUALIFICATIONS ARE MET. FIRST
AT THEY ARE LOCATED IN A COUNTY
WITH A TOTAL POPULATION OF
SEVENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE OR
FEWER. SECOND OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS OR AT LEAST 50% OF
THE SCHOOLS WITHIN THE DISTRICT
ARE DESIGNATED AS A RURAL.
SCHOOL DISTRICT UNDER THE
FEDERAL UNIVERSAL SERVICE E.
RATE PROGRAM AND THIRD IF THEY
ARE ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE GRANTS
UNDER THE FEDERAL SMALL RURAL
SCHOOL. ACHIEVEMENT PROGRAM OR
ANOTHER FEDERAL GRANT PROGRAMS
LIKE THE RURAL AND LOW INCOME
SCHOOL PROGRAM. IN WHICH
ELIGIBILITY IS DETERMINED BASED
ON A RURAL DESIGNATION SO.
HAPPY TO TAKE THAT AMENDMENT AS
WE ARE TO HAVE THAT BE PART OF
THE BILL AS WELL. ALSO SB 328%
PLEASE JUST TO CLEAN UP. THAT
WILL ENSURE THE ORIGINAL
INTENT. OF THE ENABLING
LEGISLATION WHILE MAKING
CLARIFICATIONS LAW. AND
APPROPRIATELY- RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR PORTANTINO. WE WILL NOW
GO TO THOSE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL- IT LOOKS LIKE YOU HAVE NO
LEAD WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. SO
WE WILL GO TO ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE SEEING NO ONE HERE WE
WILL GO TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SEEING NO ONE
THERE. WE WILL GO TO OUR
TELEPHONIC SERVICES MODERATOR
DO WE HAVE ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE TWENTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH. ORDER AT LEAST
THREE TO EIGHT ONE AND THEY
WILL AT THAT TIME. WE HAVE
ABOUT FIVE THANK YOU IT'LL JUST
BE ONE MOMENT- GOOD THANK YOU.
OUR FIRST COMMENTED FROM
FINANCE THIRTEEN BASEBALL HAS.
HELLO MY. YES LINE THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD- TOM YOU KNOW.
YOU REMEMBER THAT YOU KNOW
ADVOCATES ARE ON US OR EMAIL
CAN HELP YOU CAN I MEAN PART OF.
THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR.
THANK YOU RIGHT THIRTY PLACE GO
AHEAD. NINE THREE ONE WE HAD.
MY NAME IS TO BE CHILLING AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL I'M A PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSE SACRAMENTO. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WHAT LINE OF
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MANAGER MEMBER. THE PUBLIC
BETTER ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
KERN WHO. WHAT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT TWENTY EIGHT
BASEBALL HAT. LINE TWO EIGHT
TWENTY FOUR HAD. YEAH HI HELLO.
I'M A PARENT AND JOURNALISTS IN
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
THIRTY PLEASE DON'T. HELLO
HELLO THIS IS DR KELLER FROM
OUR START SCHOOL LATER
CALIFORNIANS- WE PLAYED A
SUPPORT INTO PART OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
ONE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT. TIMES
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR
MEMBERS WILL NOW GO TO
OPPOSITION I HAVE NO ONE LISTED
AS LEAD OPPOSITION SO WE WILL
LOOK TO FORTY TWO OH THREE
SEEING NO ONE HERE LET'S LOOK
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEING NO
ONE THERE WE WILL NOW GO TO THE
TELEPHONE LINES META MODERATED
WE HAVE ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF. SB
THREE TWENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE TWO
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE ONE
COMMENTING TO YOU. THANK YOU
ABOUT A LINE FORTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS JAPONICA REPRESENTING
OUR MEMBERS BY COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS. AND
THE TWENTY THREE OLDER PRETEND
THAT MEMBERS BY COUNTY OUR
POSITION AS OPPOSED SON AND
THAT CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THAT TIME THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE SENATOR MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH READING CHAIR
I'LL BE VERY BRIEF AND CHAIR
AND JUST SAY HOW MUCH I
APPRECIATE AT CENTER PORTANTINO
FOR- ADVANCING DAYS CRITICAL
CLEAN UP THE LEGISLATION. HE
MADE A COMMITMENT CENTER
PORTANTINO IS A PERSON WHO
FOLLOWS THROUGH ON HIS PROMISES
THAT TO BE ABLE TO FOCUS ON THE
RULE EXEMPTION FOCUS ON THE
ROLE STARTS TIME THEY'LL START
TIME BILL THAT WAS PASSED. LAST
YEAR AND IT IS ONE TAKE MOMENT
IT'S IMPORTANT YOU KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN A PERSON OF YOUR WORD
YOU'VE BEEN COLLABORATIVE EVERY
STEP OF THE WAY- AND GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR FOCUS ON OUR RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND I ALSO. WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO THE CHAIRWOMAN
CHAIRWOMAN LEYVA. BUT SHE HAS
BEEN MORE THAN WILLING TO BE
ABLE TO WORK ON THIS CRITICAL
ISSUE ON THE RULE EXEMPTION AS
WELL AS ONE AT A RECOGNIZE YOU
MADAM CHAIR. AND SAY THANK YOU.
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD IN
IMPROVING THE BILL AS WELL SO
THANK YOU TO THE TO THE THANK
YOU SENATOR MCGUIRE CENTER
DOLLY. THANK YOU THURMOND TRY
UNDERSTANDING WHY YOU'RE DOING
THIS CLEAN UP I JUST HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
SOMEBODY WHO REPRESENTS.
COUNTIES THAT HAVE MORE THAN
SEVENTY THOUSAND. BUT ON THE
TAKE SHASTA COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE
THE POPULATION CENTERS MAINLY.
THE READING AREA WHERE WE HAVE
A HIGH POPULATION BUT THERE. IS
A HUNDRED AND- TO MILES AWAY.
IS VERY RULED SCHOOL. OUT IN
THOSE. OUTLYING PARTS OF THE
COUNTIES. IN SO I KNOW. AND
I'VE TRIED TO. CLEAN OUT A HERO
HOW YOU THAT WOULD WORK I KNOW
THAT THERE'S OTHER CRITERIA IS
THAT I THINK WILL HELP THOSE
RULES SCHOOLS GET WE'RE GOING
TO COULD YOU JUST EXPLAIN THAT
FOR ME A LITTLE BIT BECAUSE
IT'S A LITTLE BIT UNCLEAR FOR
ME I KNOW THAT- THOSE LITTLE
SCHOOLS OUT THERE PROBABLY NOT
FOLLOWING THIS BILL RIGHT NOW I
WANT TO BE ABLE TO COMMUNICATE
WITH THEM HOW. HOW IT WOULD
AFFECT THEM. SO WE BASICALLY
DID. TWO THINGS- THIS STARTING
WITH THE COUNTIES OF SEVENTY
THOUSAND OR LESS. AND THEN
USING THE FEDERAL DEFINITION OF
RURAL SCHOOL SO THOSE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS FALL IN THAT FEDERAL
DEFINITION. FOR THOSE FEDERAL
PROGRAMS AND THEY WOULD BE
INCLUDED AS WELL SO. YOU NEED
TO ASK THEM TO SEE AN- CHATTER
MCGUIRE YOU MAY KNOW THERE.
THERE'S A THERE'S A LIST OF
THOSE DISTRICTS. THAT FALL IN
THAT ROLE THAT FEDERAL EXACT.
DEFINITION SO- THAT'S WHY WE
TRY TO CAPTURE THAT DID IT I
DIDN'T FIND THAT IN MY POCKET
MAYBE THAT'S SOMETHING I CAN
GET FROM ABSOLUTELY OKAY WE
SENT. THROUGH THE CHAIR AFFECTS
ALL RIGHT AND UP SLIGHTLY YEAH
IT SAYS- WHICH WAS CRITICAL
THERE'S THERE ARE THREE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF DEFINITIONS
WITHIN THE BILL THAT WOULD
ALLOW FOR QUALIFICATION. FOR
POTENTIAL EXEMPTION. IN WOULD
BE MORE THAN WILLING TO BE A
WORK WEEK- APPRECIATE- THE AT
THE AUTHORS OFFICE OF NOT
TAKING A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH JUST BASED OFF OF
POPULATION- IN SO THERE ARE AND
JUST BEING CANDID THERE ARE
SOME COUNTIES. THAT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED RULE THERE UNDER A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND FOR
EXAMPLE IN OUR NECK OF THE
WOODS. AND NOT ALL SCHOOLS
WOULD QUALIFY FOR THE EXEMPTION
BUT SOME SCHOOLS LIKE IN A
COUNTY A HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
WOULD BASE OFF OF THE TWO OTHER
DEFINITIONS. OF A RURAL
DISTRICT. THEN THE BUT WE WERE
TRYING TO BE FAIR SO IF YOU ARE
TRULY RURAL IN NATURE. WE
WANTED TO BE FAIR TO EXEMPT YOU
BUT IF YOU'RE A MORE
CONCENTRATED AREA THAT JUST
HAPPENS TO BE IN A RURAL.
COUNTY THEN IT WOULDN'T BE FAIR
SO WE TRIED TO USE THE FEDERAL
DEFINITION AS A AS A CATCH ALL
AS WELL SO WELL I'M ONLY OFF
YOUR BILL TODAY AND I WANT TO
GET THAT INFORMATION SO I CAN.
TAKE A LOOK AT IT BUT I
UNDERSTAND TOTALLY UNDERSTAND
WHERE YOU'RE TRYING TO HAD WITH
THIS APPRECIATED THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER DOLLY ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SENATOR TROUBLED. GOOD MORNING
SENATOR PORTANTINO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BRINGING. OF THIS
CLEAN UP BILL- AS A FORMER
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER I AM VERY
INTERESTED IN THIS ISSUE I
WASN'T IN THE LEGISLATURE WENT
THE PREVIOUSBILL WAS PASSED
BUT I HAD TO WORK LOCALLY TO
IMPLEMENTED. MY DISTRICT HAD
CONCERNS ON THE PREVIOUS BILL
AND FROM MY UNDERSTANDING- IN
THIS- COALITION LETTER THAT I
RECEIVED THEY CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BILL I KNOW
THAT IT IS YOUR INTENT TO WORK
WITH THESE GROUPS AND TRY TO
ENSURE THAT THE DEFINITION THAT
YOU'RE CREATING WORKS AND IS
FEASIBLE. BUT I WON'T BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL AT THIS
TIME UNTIL I HEAR FROM MY
DISTRICT THAT- IT WILL NOT BE
DETRIMENTAL TO THEM- AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THAT AND THE ISSUE MOVING
FORWARD- WITH. HAVING SAID THAT
I JUST- ALL LEAVE IT AT THAT
AND WE CAN- WE CAN WORK WITH
OUR LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
SEE- THE OPPOSITION THAT WE
RECEIVE THE CALL IS FROM MY
COUNTY. RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND I
DO HAVE ANOTHER LETTER FROM- I
THINK THESE ARE FROM- FROM THE
SAN MARINO COUNTY THAT HAVE
CONCERNS STILL. ON THIS ISSUE
SO BUT I DO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU MOVING FORWARD
THANK YOU. THE CENTER SEEING NO
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SENATOR PORTANTINO WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU AND
AGAIN I'LL ECHO SENATOR MCGUIRE
SENTIMENT SAID THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR FOR WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE IN YOUR STAFF TO GET THE
BILL TO WHERE IT IS TODAY- TO
MY COLLEAGUE I'M HAPPY TO SHARE
SOME OF THE RESEARCH ON THE
ORIGINAL BILL THE OTHER THIRTY
FIVE YEARS OF PEER REVIEWED
SCIENCE- ON WHY IT MAKES SENSE
TO MOVE START TIME BACK. TEST
SCORES GO UP AND SUICIDE
THOUGHT TO GO DOWN AND YOU KNOW
NOW DURING TE PANDEMIC MENTAL
HEALTH IS A CRITICAL ISSUE FOR
OUR KIDS AND WE SHOULD BE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO CREATE A
SAFE HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT FOR
THEM TO GO TO SCHOOL AND
THERE'S OVER THREE DECADES OF
RESEARCH THE SHIP SHOW THAT
THIS DOES THAT SO HAPPY TO
SHARE SOME OF THAT WITH YOU AS
WELL AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU CENTER
PORTANTINO DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
CENTER GLAZER HAS MOVED THE
BILL MA'AM CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FILE NUMBER ONE
SB THREE TWENTY EIGHT. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE LEYVA. HI LEYVA AYE BUT
TO A BOOK. MITCHELL BE NO
ATTENDEE I COURTESY I DALY.
DALY NOT VOTING GLAZER AYE
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN BY HAND
I BELIEVE THAT BUT A BILL ON
CALL MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE A BRIEF TEN MINUTE RECESS
TO ADDRESS AN ISSUE. DON'T GO
ANYWHERE.
THANK YOU EVERYONE
FOR YOUR PATIENCE WE ARE NOW
MOVING TO SB THREE SIXTY FOUR
SENATOR SKINNER PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU ARE READY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS PLEASED TO BE ABLE TO
PRESENT SB THREE SIXTY FOUR. IN
CALIFORNIA ALL CHILDREN
REGARDLESS OF INCOME. OUR
ENTITLED TO FREE GRADE SCHOOL
FREE EDUCATION K. THROUGH.
TWELVE SCHOOL LUNCH AND
BREAKFAST IS AN IMPORTANT
FEATURE OF THE SCHOOL DAY ALL
OF US KNOW THAT AND THEY ARE
LIFELINES FOR CHILDREN AND
THEIR FAMILIES HOWEVER. ONLY
THOSE CHILDREN WHOSE FAMILIES
HAVE FILLED OUT AN APPLICATION
AND BEEN VERIFIED ARE FED.
INSURED TO BE FED REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER MANY MANY OTHER
STUDENTS ARE HUNGRY OR NEED A
MEAL. AND STUDENTS CAN BE
HUNGRY EVEN IF THEY DO NOT MEET
INCOME GUIDELINES DEPENDING ON
THEIR FAMILY CIRCUMSTANCES.
MAYBE THEY DIDN'T SHOW UP AT
SCHOOL WITH THE- MONEY IN THEIR
POCKET THE BY THE SCHOOL MEALS
OR A LUNCH PREPARED AT HOME. SO
THEIR INABILITY TO HAVE BEEN
FED AFFECTS THEIR LEARNING. ALL
CHILDREN LEARN BETTER WHEN THEY
ARE FED. MANY CHILDREN ARE LEFT
OUT IN ADDITION BESIDES THE
MAIN THINGS I MENTIONED BECAUSE
FAMILIES ARE FREE TO APPLY OR
DON'T KNOW HOW TO APPLY. FOR
THEIR FAMILY IS INELIGIBLE
BECAUSE FAMILY INCOME ABOVE THE
HUNDRED AND 85% OF FEDERAL
POVERTY LINE IS STILL VERY LOW
WHEN YOU FACTOR THE COST OF
LIVING IN CALIFORNIA SO IT'S AN
INADEQUATE- LOW INCOME LEVEL
DETERMINATION. WHAT IS B. THREE
SIXTY FOUR WAS PUT US ON THE
PATH OF BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE
ALL SCHOOL CHILDREN WITHOUT
MEALS WITHOUT MEANS TESTING
SCHOOL MEALS WHICH WOULD SOLVE
HUNGER WHICH WOULD SOLVE THE
STIGMA OF GETTING A FREE MEAL.
WHICH WOULD ELIMINATE FAMILY
SCHOOL MEAL DEBT AND CUT MUCH
ADMINISTRATION BUREAUCRATIC
COSTS FOR SCHOOLS AND ALSO
ALLOW OUR STATE TO MAXIMIZE OUR
COLLECTION OF FEDERAL DOLLARS
BECAUSE WE STILL LEAVE MANY
ANTI HUNGER MONIES PROVIDED BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON THE
TABLE AND DO NOT. PART ABLE TO
COLLECTED. MEALS FOR ALL
PROGRAMS. HAVE BEEN PROVEN TO
BOOST SCHOOL ATTENDANCE AND
ACHIEVEMENT. AND THAT'S OUR
PURPOSE AND NOW I WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE OUR- MY WITNESSES BE ABLE
TO SPEAK TO THE BILL. I HAVE
STEPHANIE BRUCE WHO IS
NUTRITION SERVICES DIRECTOR FOR
THE PALM SPRINGS IN UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. AND MY SECOND-
WITNESS IN SUPPORT IS TO LARA
STRAND FLORISTS WHO'S THE
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR OUR
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU CENTER
SKINNER- WITNESSES I THINK YOU
READY TO GO MS BRUCE PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CHAIR LEYVA
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
AM STEPHANIE BRUCE NUTRITION
SERVICES DIRECTOR FOR PALM
SPRINGS UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
WE ARE PART OF A GROWING
NETWORK OF ALMOST ONE HUNDRED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT
PARTICIPATE IN THE CENTER FOR
EAGLE AT RISK THE- CALIFORNIA
STATE FOR CALIFORNIA KIDS
INITIATIVE. I AM PLEASED TO
SUPPORT SB THREE SIXTY FOUR
BECAUSE IT WOULD MAKE
SIGNIFICANT STEPS TOWARDS
ENDING CHILD HUNGER IN
CALIFORNIA. PROVIDING MEALS AT
NO COST TO ALL STUDENTS WOULD
REDUCE CHILDHOOD HUNGER BY
ELIMINATING STIGMA AND ENSURE
THAT STUDENTS ARE PREPARED TO
LEARN. MY COLLEAGUES IN FULL IN
SCHOOL NUTRITION AND I HAVE
SEEN FIRST HAND THE STUDENTS
THAT GO HUNGRY WHEN THEY DO NOT
HAVE MONEY TO PAY FOR SCHOOL
MEALS. IN FACT I HAVE STUDENTS
WHO SHOW UP ON MONDAYS FOR
BREAKFAST AND TELL ME THEY DO
NOT THEY DID NOT EAT OVER THE
WEEKEND BECAUSE IT WASN'T THEIR
TURN TO EAT. IT'S HEARTBREAKING
IT'S UNJUST AND IT'S
UNSUSTAINABLE. SINCE THERE'S SO
MUCH NEED IN MY SCHOOL DISTRICT
WE HAVE BEEN ONE OF THE FEW
DISTRICTS ABLE TO IMPLEMENT THE
COMMUNITY ELIGIBILITY PROVISION
DISTRICT WIDE TO PROVIDE EVERY
STUDENT WITH FREE SCHOOL MEALS.
THIS HAS REDUCED ABSENTEEISM
DECREASE TARDINESS AND PREPARED
KIDS TO LEARN ONE SCHOOL NURSE
IT WAS THE BEST PROGRAM HE HAS
EVER SEEN BECAUSE IT ELIMINATED
ALL HUNGER RELATED VISITS TO
HIS OFFICE. SB THREE SIXTY FOUR
WOULD ALLOW EVERY DISTRICT TO
THE FEDERAL LABOR SINCE THE
START OF CODED. FREE SCHOOL
MEALS FOR ALL SPOKE ALL SHOULD
NOT END WITH THE WAIVERS EXPIRE
ON SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. SB THREE SIXTY FOUR
WILL REDUCE ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS FOR SCHOOL FOOD SERVICE
DEPARTMENTS WHEN ARE DISTRICTS
WHICH DEFEATING EVERY STUDENT
AT NO COST WE WERE ABLE TO
SHIFT THREE LEE AND THE LABOR
OF THREE FULL TIME EMPLOYEES.
FROM PROCESSING MAIL
APPLICATIONS SENDING OUT
LETTERS AND ANSWERING PHONE
CALLS FROM CONCERNED PARENTS
INSTEAD THAT STOP TIME IS NOW
REDIRECTED TO CREATING BETTER
TASTING FRESHER MEALS THAT HAVE
INCREASED PARTICIPATION.
FINALLY THIS BILL WOULD
PRIORITIZE. FRESH FRUIT FOOD
FROM CALIFORNIA FARMERS THERE
IS NO BETTER. TO THE- OF OUR
MEAL. AND SUPPORTING OUR LOCAL
FARMERS AND OUR LOCAL ECONOMY.
MY DISTRICT HAS BEEN ABLE TO
PROVIDE ONE MILLION POUNDS OF
FRESH CALIFORNIA GROWN PRODUCE
TO OUR STUDENTS. SINCE THE
START OF THE PANDEMIC. BE
INCENTIVES FOR FRESHLY PREPARED
IN CALIFORNIA GROWN SCHOOL
MEALS IN SB THREE SIXTY FOUR
WILL ALLOW US TO STRENGTHEN
THESE RELATIONSHIPS WITH
CALIFORNIA FARMERS. KEEPING
THEIR FOR THE FARMERS AND THEIR
EMPLOYEES IN BUSINESS AND THEIR
FAMILIES SAID AS A RESULT. FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS IN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND FARMERS I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT SB THREE SIXTY FOUR
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME AGAIN
AND SO ARE THREE AND FOUR AS
THEY REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION.
RIGHT IN FOR YOU ARE FINANCIAL
WORKERS ON THE FARM OF THE THEY
CAN DOWN THE BUT THERE ALSO ON
THE LINE IN HUNGER. ARE SO
WORKERS ARE DAILY AND THEY NOW.
FOR MANY OF OUR STUDENTS THE
DEAL THEY THAT THE ONLY MALE
THEY WERE ALL THE- WE KNOW IN
YOU'RE HUNGRY DO NOT DO WELL AS-
THIS IS A TERRIBLE ENACTED.
THERE MUST BE REMEDY. YEAH
SUPPORT SENATE BILL THREE THREE
FOR THE PERMANENTLY THE POUND
POLICY THE PROVIDE FREE MEALS
ALL STUDENTS. ARE BEING ABLE.
COOL TREATING AN ANTI HUNGER.
LIKE THIS IS NOT A GOOD FOR.
BUT IT'S ALL GOOD TO THE CLASS
OF. BEAT AND NOURISH THEM. FIVE
MORE HOURS JOHN IN FOR SERVICE
WORKERS WHO ARE LITTLE PUT
THEIR ON THE- DURING THE
PANDEMIC SEE OUR STUDENTS. AT
THE LOWER PAID WORKERS NURSES
WHO- ON A MINUTE WAGE OR
SLIGHTLY MORE. THAN A
PREDOMINATELY WOMEN. MANY COULD
SERVE WORKER. HAVE MORE THAN
ONE JOB TO EARN A LIVING WHEN
YOU SHOULD BE IN THE FIRST
WORKER. AND THEN OUR FOOD
SERVICE WORKERS IN OUR BUS
DRIVER TEAMED UP AND DELIVERED
MEALS. DIDN'T WHO WERE AT
SCHOOL JUDITH LEARNING. THEY
ALSO PROVIDED MEAL DIDN'T
DIDN'T SET A- IN LEARN. SENATE
BILL THREE FOUR ENSURE THAT ALL.
HAVE AT LEAST TWO MEALS A DAY
AND ESSENTIAL SERVICE WORKERS
WILL BE TO SERVE THAT WE ASK
FOR YOUR NOW. THANK YOU. BEFORE
WE GO TO WITNESSES AND OTHER
ADDITIONAL SENTENCES OF CENTER
DID YOU ACCEPT THE CA AMEND.
YES APOLLO THAT I NOT OPEN WITH
THAT ABSOLUTELY THE TECH MA'AM
NO PROBLEM YOU VERY. WILL GO TO
THOSE IN SOME HERE IN FORTY TWO
OR THREE SEEING WE WILL GO TO
ROOM TWENTY. SEEING NONE WILL
NOW GO TO THE TELEPHONE LINES
MADAME MODERATOR TO WE HAVE
ANYONE QUEUING UP WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF SB
THREE SIXTY FOUR. THANK YOU YOU
WISH SPEAK SEPT. OF SB THREE
SIX FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT AND WE HAVE A ABOUT.
THIRTY TWO IN Q. WATERLINE
ALIVE ENTRIES GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR SO BROWN
LOOKS SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND EDUCATORS BUT MEMBERS
OF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING AND YOU'RE CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SUCH WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND WE STAND
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE SIX FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CHRISTOPHER SPONSORS POLICY
ADVOCATE WESTERN CENTER LONG
POVERTY WEREN'T STRONG
SUPPORTER. THANK YOU RYAN SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS MICHELLE
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER INCOME
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. EMILY ROSENBERGER WITH
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION WHERE. THANK YOU I'M
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS KEVIN INFO
FRIENDS THE CANADIAN
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA.
COURT THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
REBECCA MARKETS REPRESENTING
THE CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY
INSTITUTE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I'M THIRTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SANDERS
MADE BENJAMIN TAYLOR ON BEHALF
OF JONATHAN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING OF JULY GIVEN FROM THE
SAN FRANCISCO MARIN BANK WIRE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE- THANK
YOU RYAN SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR- MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CAPULETS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HER
HEALTH RECREATION AND DANCE.
WORK THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS IRENE
REYNOLDS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
NUTRITION SERVICES AT OAKLAND
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU RYAN
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS AND RETAIN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS REPRESENTING OUR PARTY
ONE NUMBERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU RYAN FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
DEREK WALCOTT ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES REGIONAL FOOD BANK
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING ANOTHER
WOULD ON BEHALF OF THAT CAN
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. THANK YOU
I'M FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KERN SHOW CRIME AGAIN AND EVEN
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
I'M FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL NURSES ORGANIZATION
WEARING STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MORE SANTA ANA SAN FRANCISCO
MARIA FULL BANG WE ARE STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS HEIDI MAKE
YOU WITH GOOD FOR PEOPLE THE
FOOD BANK FOR HUMBOLDT COUNTY
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
I'M FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS MELANIE
FLOOD REPRESENTING SACRAMENTO
FOOD BANK AND FAMILY SERVICES
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU RYAN SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE SEVEN EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BLIND THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
COMPANY PROJECTION OPEN HEART
KITCHEN IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
SUZANNE WILLIS FROM SECOND
HARVEST FOOD BANK SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE SIXTY FOUR. THANK YOU
RYAN SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING AND THE SAN
WITH FRIENDS OF THE EARTH CLEAR
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS TO ME AYE THAR
AYE MAGENTA STUDENT FROM SENATE
DISTRICT FOURTEEN AND I STAND
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THREE
SIX FOUR. THANK YOU I'M SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SLIDESHOW AND
I AM ME CHEN UP STUDENTS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU OF
MINE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD- GOOD MORNING THIS IS
MARVIN BEYOND WITH COMMON SENSE
MEDIA AND AS A PERSONAL
STRUGGLE WITH HUNDRED THE CHILD
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
RYAN SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
SHOWING ME THERE WITH COUNCIL
RESTORING AMERICAN MISSION
READINESS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS ELECTED BY WINTER
AND I'M WITH THE FOOD RESEARCH
AND ACTION CENTER AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU I'M
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING YOUR COMMENT TO ON
ON BEHALF OF ALAMEDA COUNTY
COMMUNITY FOOD BANK IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WILL MOVE ON THE LINE SHIFTING
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FIVE
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
MOMENT FOR A NEXT COMMENT. NINE
FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
CROWDS WITH WESTSIDE FOOD BANK
IN SANTA MONICA WE ARE AND FROM
THE PORT OF SB THREE SIXTY FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS KIMBERLY JONATHAN TO
THE NEWS EDUCATION ACT
HUMANIZATION COMPRISING OF FOUR
THAT NUMBER I'M IF I COULD GET
YOU THAT IT SHOULD NOT AND
MEANT. PEOPLE THANK YOU I'M FOR
IT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME RACHEL OPEN
SECOND HARVEST THE SILICON WE
ARE INSTRUCTED OF THE- THANK
YOU RANGE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE FIVE ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BY TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING CARE MEMBERS TIFFANY
MARC ON BEHALF OF THE CENTER
FOR FOOD SAFETY AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I NEED YOU
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
LIZ FENTON I'M REPRESENTING
OFFICE SAID CAT TAYLOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT AT THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
I'M TWELFTH PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS PATRICIA
NICHOLS BUTLER WITH COMMUNITY
ACTION PARTNERSHIP OF SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THREE SIX
FOUR. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR OUR MEMBERS MICHAEL
RAT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OF SANTA
CLARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT EIGHTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING AT THE HELP
AND FROM THE SENATE RICO INNER
CITY AND STRONG SUPPORT NO
POSITION. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING JAMIE MORGAN ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I SHOW NO LEAD
OPPOSITION ANYONE IN FORTY TWO
OH THREE I SEE NO ONE. NO ONE
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN WE WILL NOW
GO TO THE PHONE LINES MATTER
MODERATED WE HAVE ANYONE COMING
UP TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SB
THREE SIXTY FOUR. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB THREE SIX FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK MENTAL MODERATOR WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
DO WE HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
CENTER PAN. THANK YOU CENTER
SKINNER FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AND- CERTAINLY- MAKE
COMPELLING ARGUMENTS FOR THIS
BILL I DID HAVE A QUESTION AN
ANALYSIS- THEY TALKED ABOUT THE
ISSUE THE CENTRAL KITCHENS IN
KNOW THAT MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS
DOYOU CENTRAL KITCHENS AS A
WAY TO MORE EFFICIENTLY UP.
THOSE FRESH MIGLIOR TALKING
ABOUT- HE JUST'S NOT INSIDE OF
CAN YOU CAN SPEAK TO- THE
SUGGESTION IN THE ANALYSIS THAT
WE ALLOW THE SCHOOLS TO BUILD
THE POOL THEIR FUNDS. FROM THE-
GRANTS TO THE PER SCHOOL SITE
TO BE ABLE TO- TO DEVELOPER YOU
CENTRAL KITCHENS TO ACHIEVE THE
GAMES OF THIS BILL. CERTAINLY
SO- WE'RE DEFINITELY OPEN TO
LOOKING AT THAT PARTICULAR
MOMENT THE- THESE GRANT PROGRAM
WAS STARTED A GOOD NUMBER OF
YEARS BACK IN FACT I BELIEVE
WAS TWENTY THIRTEEN OR
FOURTEEN. WHERE WE THE STATE
STARTED OFFERING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS GRANTS BECAUSE WE
RECALL THERE WAS A PERIOD OF
TIME WHERE DISTRICTS HAD CLOSED
KITCHENS AND THEN THERE WAS A
MOVE TO BEGIN TO RE OPEN AND SO
WE STARTED A GRANT PROGRAM.
THAT WOULD ENABLE DISTRICTS TO
EITHER BRING BACK THEIR FOOD
SERVICE OR DO CENTRAL KITCHENS
ARE VARIETY OF THINGS AND THAT
GRANT PROGRAM NEVER- WHICH WE
SAY- WAS BIASED AGAINST A
CENTRAL COMMITTEE KITCHEN
VERSUS A ON SITE SO I WANTED WE
I WILL DEFINITELY MAKE SURE TO
LOOK AT OURS. THANK BECAUSE WE
DO NOT WANT THAT BIAS BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY IF THAT'S THE MOST
EFFICIENT WAY FOR THE DISTRICT
TO DO SO WE'D WANT THEM TO BE
ABLE TO DO SO. EVERY SHEET TO
YOU LOOKING INTO THAT- AND
CERTAINLY- HAPPY TO MOVE TO
BUILD APPROPRIATE TIME THANK
YOU. CENTER TROUBLED. JUST
WANTED TO- THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND
FOR REALLY WATCHING OUT FOR
LITTLE OUR KIDDOS IN OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS I THINK- WHEN YOU
HEAR THE TESTIMONIES OF PEOPLE
GOING HUNGRY AND- I COMPLETELY
AGREE WITH YOU AS FAR AS THE
RESEARCH GOES IN THE DATA SHEET
THAT THAT THE OPPORTUNE TO HAVE
REVIEWED MANY MUCH OF THAT. IN
ORDER TO SUPPORT- YOU KNOW OUR
MEALS AND HOW THAT WILL BENEFIT
THE OVERALL WELL BEING AND
DEVELOPMENT OF OUR CHILDREN AND
PERFORMANCE IN SCHOOLS- IT SAY.
HE SHORT TERM INVESTMENT FOR
LONG- FOR A LONG BENEFITS ON
THE COME FROM IT'S A THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THAT APPRECIATED.
THANK YOU CENTER CENTER DOLLY.
THANK YOU BRING THIS BILL FORD
I JUST. WANTED TO SHARE WITH
YOU AN EXPERIENCE THAT- I
WITNESSED ACTUALLY. PURFLING
THINK IT'S A GREAT IDEA TO
ALLOW THESE CHILDREN TO TAKE A
TO GET FED UP AND- NO MATTER
WHAT YOUR INCOME IS I MEAN
YOU'RE YOU'RE- HERE STATEMENTS
ABOUT THE COST OF THE IN
CALIFORNIA ARE SKYROCKETING AS
A FACT. WE ALL KNOW THAT AND
SOMETHING WE SHOULD WORK ON IT
WHEN OTHER AREAS AS WELL. BUT I
KNOW THAT TIME AT LEAST IN THE
LAW SCHOOL DISTRICT WHERE. MY
CHILDREN ATTENDED AND- I
WITNESSED ACTUALLY WERE KIDS
YOU KNOW THERE'S LEFTOVER FOOD
SOMETIMES. AND THE LAW DOESN'T
ALLOW THE SERVICE PROVIDERS THE
TWO TEACHERS- THE COOKS TO
ACTUALLY LET THOSE KIDS TAKE
THAT FOOD I WITNESSED KIDS
STEALING IT BASICALLY WHEN THAT
WHEN THEY'RE NOT WATCHING AND
PUTTING IT IN THEIR BACKPACKS
SO THEY HAVE SOMETHING TO EAT
WHEN THEY GET HOME. AND SO
THERE WAS SOME WAY WE COULD
CRAFT AN ABILITY THAT FOOD'S
GONNA GET THROWN IN AND IT GETS
THROWN IN THE DUMPSTER AT THE
END OF THE DAY IT'S PART OF
THAT 40% OF THE FOOD TO GET
WASTED IN AMERICA BECAUSE IT
JUST DOESN'T GET IT DOESN'T
MEET THE CRITERIA SO I WOULD
ASK IF THERE IS SOME. ABILITY
TO BE ABLE TO USE THAT FOOD
IT'S GOING TO BASICALLY BE
THROWN AWAY AND IT LET THOSE
CHILDREN TAKE IT WITH THEM
BECAUSE A LOT OF THEM THAT WAS
THEIR DINNER AND THEY WERE THEY
WERE SNEAKING THAT WHEN THEY
WHEN THEY WERE GRABBING
OPPORTUNITIES OR EVEN TAKEN
OFFICE SOMEBODY ELSE'S. PLAY
WHEN THEY DIDN'T FINISH IT IT'S
JUST. THIS WASTE AND IT'S AS-
SOME I WANTED TO MATCH TO YOU
THAT MY- IF THERE'S A WAY TO DO
IT I DON'T KNOW I KNOW THERE'S
FOOD. BORNE ALLERGIES AND OR OR
THINGS THAT HAPPEN TO FOOD
AFTER YOU STORE BUT- THERE
SHOULD BE COULD BE WAY ME WE
COULD. SELL THAT UP AND- SEND
IT HOME WITH THEM. THANK YOU
CENTER DOLLY CENTER GLAZER.
THANK YOU CHAIR- CENTER'S GONNA
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL TO US TODAY-
IT'S CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT I
AM HAPPY TO SUPPORT I KNOW
WE'RE NOT THE FISCAL COMMITTEE
BUT- COULD YOU JUST AT LEAST-
GIVE US SOME SENSE OF THAT
COSTS THAT SUIT AT THIS BILL IS
EXPECTED TO BE. I APPRECIATE
THE QUESTION WE- WE DON'T HAVE
THE FULL COST. ESTIMATE YET.
BECAUSE PART OF IT'S GOING TO
DEPEND ON. WHETHER CERTAIN OF
THE- PROGRAMS THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAD ENACTED. AT THE
MOMENT THEY'RE SCHEDULED TO
SUNSET. IF THEY CONTINUE
HOWEVER. THEN THE- WHAT. NUMBER
ONE CALIFORNIA ALREADY IS NOT.
MAXIMIZING ITS RECEIPT. OF
FEDERAL FUNDS FOR SCHOOL MEALS.
SO ON WE'RE STILL CALCULATING
EVEN IF THERE'S NO CHANGE BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
SWEAT. THE THIS BILL WOULD COST
US IF WE WERE ABLE TO MAXIMIZE
THAT WE'RE STILL DOING THAT.
THOSE CALCULATIONS. HOWEVER IF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WERE TO.
ON EITHER ENACT PERMANENTLY OR
EXTEND SOME OF THE PROGRAMS
THAT WERE SET UP. DURING THE
PANDEMIC. THEN THAT WOULD
REDUCE CALIFORNIA'S COST EVEN
FURTHER SO WILL WE WILL BE
DOING. TO ESTIMATES ON ON THE
COST. AND YOU MADE REFERENCE IN
YOUR OPENING STATEMENT ABOUT
FEDERAL MONEY BEING LEFT ON THE
TABLE YES YOU HAVE AN ESTIMATE
OF WHAT THAT. PROJECTION IS-
I'M POLICIES I DO NOT HAVE THAT
NUMBER AT THE TOP AT MY
FINGERTIPS BUT I'M CERTAINLY
WILLING TO GET IT FOR YOU. I
KNOW THAT- YOU IN IT WITH
ANOTHER HAD ON HAVE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF TRYING TO
MAKE THESE DIFFICULT BUDGET
CHOICES YES. FOR MANY MANY GOOD
THINGS AND- CERTAINLY THIS IS
ONE THAT- IS FOUNDATIONAL FOR
OUR STUDENTS. TO DO WELL IN
SCHOOL AND TO LIVE HEALTHY
LIVES SO. I APPRECIATE THE
CHALLENGES THAT YOU'LL FACE AND
NOT TRYING TO. FIGURE THAT OUT
BUT HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL
AND WITH THE BILL TODAY
APPROPRIATE TIME. OKAY BIG
CENTER GLAZER. SEEING NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
CENTERS. CAN I WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU TO- ONE OF THE
THINGS I DID MANAGE WAS THAT.
IN THIS P. YEAR. THERE WERE
MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS SO. A HAS
WE KNOW MOST GOALS WERE CLOSE.
AND YET WE STILL HAD. THAT WERE
HUNGRY OR NEEDED A- AND SO MY
MANY TO CAN THEIR MIL PROGRAM.
AND IN MAY CASES THEY WERE
PROVIDING MEALS BEYOND. THAT
WHICH THEY PROVIDED PRE PAN.
AND IN A BECAUSE THE TWO FOR
PROBE. THE PBT AND ANOTHER. THE
SCHOOL TO. SOME SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WERE ABLE TO. I WOULD
SAY COVER THEIR FULL COSTS BUT
YOU KNOW COVER SOME LEVEL OF
THAT COST OTHER SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WENT INTO DEBT IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE THE MEALS THAT
THEY PROVIDED DURING THIS
PANDEMIC TIME TO A PROVISION OF
THE BILL THAT I DID NOT MENTION
IS THE ABILITY FOR CALIFORNIA
TO CONTINUE A MEAL PROGRAM
WENDOUREE ARE SCHOOL CLOSURES.
BECAUSE WE COULD FACE ANOTHER
IN AT LET'S SAY- ANY KIND OF
DISASTER WHERE THERE WOULD
MIGHT MIGHT BE SIGNED AND WE
KNOW THAT THE SCHOOL MEAL
PROGRAMS ARE STILL SO ESSENTIAL
FOR THE STUDENTS. SO THAT'S ONE
ASPECT OF THE BILL THE OTHER
ASPECT THAT WAS MENTIONED BY
SOME CALLERS THAT ARE DID NOT
EMPHASIZE WHICH I SHOULD HAVE
IS THAT ANOTHER COMPONENT THIS
BILL. IS- THE CONCEPT OF
PROVIDING MEALS FOR OUR
STUDENTS AS PART OF EDUCATION
HAS BEEN AROUND FOR A LONG
TIME. BUT THE WORK THAT HAS
BEEN DONE OVER THE LAST SAY
FIFTEEN YEARS IS THERE IS THIS
HUGE NETWORK OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. THAT HAVE BEEN BOTH.
BRINGING BACK THEIR- INDIVIDUAL
KITCHENS WERE. FOR CENTRALIZED
KITCHENS AND PREPARING MORE
MEALS ON SITE AND DEVELOPING.
RELATIONSHIPS AND PURCHASE
PROGRAMS DIRECTLY WITH
CALIFORNIA GROWERS AND
CALIFORNIA FOOD PRODUCERS FOOD
MANUFACTURERS. TO CUT THEIR
COSTS AND IF WE THINK ABOUT OUR
OWN AGRICULTURE ECOSYSTEMS
CALIFORNIA GETS THE LEAST
FEDERAL SUBSIDIES FOR THE CROPS
THAT WE GROW. WE ARE FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES IN SECTION NOT OR DO
NOT GET MANY OF THE FEDERAL
SUBSIDIES SO. BEYOND WHEN OUR
SCHOOLS CAN HAVE THOSE KIND OF
DIRECT RELATIONSHIPS WITH OUR
GROWERS IT GREATLY HELPS OUR AG
PRODUCERS AND SO THERE'S A
COMPONENT THIS BILL THIS GREW
OUT OF THIS NETWORK. AND
THERE'S A COMPONENT OF THE BILL
THAT WOULD. ALLOW FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE THOSE RELATIONSHIPS
AND ALSO APPLY FOR GRANTS FOR
THAT SO IT BENEFITS OUR AG
PRODUCERS ADDITIONALLY. SO WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
AND APPRECIATE THE GOOD
DISCUSSION WE'VE HAD THANK YOU
CENTER SKINNER. THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR PAN BUT
BEFORE WE GET TO THAT STANDARD
DOLLAR TO YOUR POINT ALL IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN SB FIVE FIVE
SEVEN WAS PASSED. WHICH DOES
ALLOW FOR SOME FOOD SHARING I
KNOW ONE OF MY SCHOOL DISTRICTS
RIALTO THEY HAVE A FOOD SHARING
TABLE NOT ALL FOOD FOR THE
PURPOSES YOU STATED CAN BE PUT
THERE BUT I THINK SOME SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE MOVING TO THAT
AND WE JUST MORE INFORMATION ON
FIVE FIVE SEVEN THAT YOU CAN
SHAREWITH YOUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT. SO WITH THAT MATAMATA
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ITEM NUMBER TWO SB THREE
SIXTY FOUR THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HUMAN SERVICES
LEYVA. HI THEY'VE AYE OCHO
ABODE I WHICH WILL BUILD A
COURTESY HI FOR TENNESSEE I.
DELI I GLAZER HI GLAZER AYE.
PAN HI AND I. BELIEVE THE BILL
IN CONGRESS MY TO VOTE ON.
THANK YOU CENTERS HAVE A GOOD.
REST OF THE DAY. AND NEXT UP
UNDER A- WITH B. C. NINE NINE.
HOLD ON SECOND SO. I THINK HOLD
ON ONE SECOND GONNA WHY THAT
DOWN FOR YOU. THEY CAN ALSO.
WELCOME CENTER EGGMAN PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TODAY I WANT TO PRESENT
TO SB SIX NINETY NINE- WHICH
DEALS WITH THE ISSUE OF SCHOOL
CLIMATE. RESEARCH INDICATES
THAT SCHOOL CLIMATE STRONGLY
INFLUENCES STUDENTS MOTIVATION
TO LEARN AND IMPROVE ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT- WE ALL KNOW THAT
PEOPLE DO BETTER WHEN THEY ARE
IN A IN A POSITIVE ENVIRONMENT-
ALREADY SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
REQUIRED EVERY OTHER YEAR TO DO
A- CLIMATE SURVEY- SO THIS IS
JUST TAKING IT A STEP FURTHER
AND JUST SAYING THE RESULTS OF
THAT CLIMATE SURVEY SHOULD
SERVE AS A STATE WIDE INDICATOR
AND BE ON THE DASHBOARD SO
PARENTS OR COMMUNITY MEMBERS OR
STUDENTS THEMSELVES CAN LOOK
AROUND. AND SEE WHAT THE
CLIMATE IS SO THE- THE IDEA IS
THAT THERE'S ALREADY SOME
EXISTING TOOLS BUT THAT FROM
THOSE EXISTING TOOLS SOME
COMMON INDICATORS WILL BE
DEVELOPED SO THAT WE CAN THEN
MEASURE AND PUT THAT STATEWIDE
ACROSS ON ON DASHBOARDS AND SO
AGAIN PEOPLE CN REFER TO THAT
AND THEN WE CAN ALSO DEVELOP-
SPECIFIC INTERVENTIONS BASED ON
THE DATA TO BE ABLE TO SUGGEST
WAYS TO IMPROVE. THE CLIMATE WE
KNOW IN OUR TIMES OF A EXTREME
POLARIZATION- A LOT OF- TENSION
IN THE AIR THAT THAT OFTEN
FILTERS DOWN TO OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE AND THE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH THEIR
EXISTING IN SO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE TRACKING THAT
AND THAT THEN WE CAN DO A
APPROPRIATE INTERVENTIONS AS
NEEDED- WITH ME HERE TODAY I
HAVE SEVERAL LOUIS. LUIS LITTLE
YES EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF TEACH
PLUS CALIFORNIA AND JENNY SHE
WOULD KING AN EDUCATOR WHO
TEACHES ENGLISH AT AMADOR
VALLEY HIGH SCHOOL IN
PLEASANTON TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT VERY GOOD THANK YOU
SENATOR EGGMAN WITNESSES PLEASE
PROCEED I THINK ASA CEREBELLUM.
LEWIS IS FIRST. GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING CHARLIE EVENTS
JANITORS I AM SURE. EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF TEACHING CALIFORNIA
AND THE SPONSORS OF SB SIX
NINETY NINE. I HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF WORKING WITH
AMAZING EDUCATORS FROM AROUND
THE STATE INCLUDING THANK YOU
CAME WHO YOU'LL HEAR FROM IN A
MOMENT. ARE POLICY FELLOWS
DURING WHAT IS UNDOUBTEDLY THE
MOST OVERWHELMING YEAR OF THEIR
CAREERS. HAVE BEEN COMMITTED TO
FINDING SOLUTIONS TO THE MOST
PERSISTENT CHALLENGES THAT THE
CRISES OF THE LAST YEAR HAVE
UNDERSCORED. DEAN HOW THE
SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL TOLL ON
STUDENT THIS YEAR HAS
REINFORCED HOW IMPORTANT IT IS.
FOR OUR SCHOOLS TO PRIORITIZE
THE NEEDS OF THE WHOLE CHILD.
AND WHILE MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IN CALIFORNIA HAVE EMBRACED
THAT IMPERATIVE. THAT IS NOT
THE CASE EVERYWHERE. A GROWING
BODY OF RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
WHEN THOSE. THOSE SCHOOL. FEEL
SAFE VALUED CARED FOR RESPECTED
AND ENGAGED LEARNING INCREASES.
AND IT ALLOWS STUDENTS TO GROW
SOCIALLY AND EMOTIONALLY.
NEVERTHELESS EVEN WITH THIS
ROBUST EVIDENCE SOME TEACHERS
WERE FRUSTRATED THAT DISTRICT
AND SCHOOL LEADERS WERE NOT
INVESTING TIME AND RESOURCES
AND SCHOOL CLIMATE. WE KNOW
THAT THE ISSUE OF SCHOOL
CLIMATE IN GENERAL BEING IS NOT
A NEW ONE. BUT HOW CAN WE
ENSURE THAT THERE IS MORE
CONSISTENT FOCUS ON THESE
ISSUES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WE'RE HOPEFUL AND HELP TRANS TO
HEALTHIER FAST MOVING TO A
SYSTEM OF ACCOUNTABILITY THAT
FOCUSES ON MULTIPLE MEASURES
INCLUDING SCHOOL CLIMATE DATA.
BUT BECAUSE LEDS ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO USE ANY PARTICULAR
INSTRUMENT. THERE IS NOT
CONSISTENT YET ACROSS THE
STATE. AS A RESULT THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DASHBOARD
DOES NOT REFLECT THE FINDINGS
OF THE SURVEY OR ANY REFLECTION
OF THE DISPARATE EXPERIENCES
BETWEEN GROUPS IT. FURTHERMORE
SCHOOL CLIMATE SURVEY ARE IN.
THAT IS USED TO IDENTIFY ELLIE
EIGHT. AGAIN MY DISTRICT WHO
NEED ADDITIONAL SUPPORT. WE
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN DO BETTER
TO CREATE A SYSTEMIC OKAY SOME
POSSIBLE CLIMATE. SB SIX NINETY
NINE WILL PRODUCE COMPARABLE
DATA THAT CAN BE USED TO INFORM
POLICIES AND IMPROVE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND CAPACITY
BUILDING PROPERTY DISTRICT
COURT BY. BOTH LEADING REBEL OF
THE FLEXIBILITY. WITH
CONSISTENT AND COMPARABLE DATA
THE STATEMENT THEY CALLED US
WILL BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY
ELEAZAR STRUGGLING TO CREATE
POSITIVE SCHOOL CLIMATE FOR ALL
STUDENTS ONE FOR PARTICULAR
SUBGROUPS OF STUDENTS. AND GET
THEM HELP THROUGH THE STATE RUN
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT. HE WILL ALSO
IDENTIFY. THOSE THAT ARE
TELLING IS MODELED. AT SIX
NINETY ON BILLS ON PREVIOUS IN
THE- WITH OTHER PAPA BEING.
WHEN IS THE SB SIX NINETY NINE
MAKE CLEAR THE GOAL OF
ELEVATING THE STATE WITH THE IN
THE- ON FOOTING OTHER
INDICATORS WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THE SURVEYS ALONG WILL NOT
CHANGE PRACTICE AND CULTURE
SCHOOL. BUT THIS IS AN
ESSENTIAL STEP TO DRIVE THAT
CHANGE STATEWIDE ON BEHALF OF
TEACH PLUS IN OUR FUTURE
LEADERS I URGE YOU TO PASS SB
SIX NINETY NINE. THANK YOU
MISSOULA'S SOME ASK OUR- BOB
FOLKS TESTIFYING TO AND KEEP TO
ME. WELL NOW GO TO MS HEWITT.
PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD MORNING
CHARLIE VAN SENATORS MY NAME IS
JENNY HERE KING MY CAR DOWN
THERE SHE IN HER. ENGLISH
TEACHER AT AMADOR VALLEY HIGH
SCHOOL IN PLEASANTON UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND SENATOR
GLAZERS DISTRICT AND EACH PART
CALIFORNIA POLITICS HELLO. I
NEEDED SOMETHING I THOUGHT A
LOT ABOUT AS A TEACHER
ESPECIALLY WORKING IN A
DISTRICT TO DEMOGRAPHICS. ARE
GROWING MORE DIVERSE EACH YEAR.
ACTUALLY HAVE EXPRESSED LAST.
TO SCHOOL THEN BEFORE. I TRIED
HARD MITIGATE IMPACT OF REMOTE
LEARNING BY BUILDINGS. AND
CHECKING IN ON MY STUDENTS WILL
BE WHICH THE WORK OF COOL
CLIMATE. BE THE ONLY BY INTO
TEACHERS. AND AS I TRANSITION
TO A PARTIAL IN PERSON MODEL
THE PRESSURE TO DO THE WORK
FIELD EVEN HAPPIER. WE ARE I'VE
BEEN BY THE TO SERVE ON A
DISTRICT. THAT WE AT THE A- IN
THAT. HAD TO THERE ENOUGH
EXPERIENCES SHOULD BASED ON MY
DISTRICT INDICATORS WE EXPECT.
TO RESPOND. TO THE
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER OF
BLACK STUDENTS BEING
DISCIPLINED AND OF HISPANIC AND
LATINO STUDENTS BEING PLACED IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
OFFICE IS ALREADY TO LIGHT HOW
IMPACTFUL. INDICATORS YOU CAN
BE. ON THE OTHER HAND MY
DISTRICT HAS NOT DONE THE SAME
INTENTIONAL WORK IN RESPONSE
FISCAL CLIMATE DATA. OUR RECENT
BUT PRE PANDEMIC CALIFORNIA
HEALTHY SCHOOL SURVEY DATA
SHOWS THAT THE AMOUNT OF
STUDENTS IN OUR DISTRICT THAT
HE'LL ATTEND. SCHOOL CONNECTED
MESSAGE DROPPED IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AN AVERAGE OF 5%
ACROSS GRADE LEVELS. NOTABLY
THAT PERCENTAGE DIFFERENCE WHY
DID TO A 13% DROP FOR HISPANIC
AND LATINO STUDENTS EACH AND A
29% DROP OF BLACK STUDENTS. ARE
DISTRICT SCHOOL CLIMATE DATA
ALSO SHOWED SIMILAR PATTERNS
WHEN LOOKING AT SCHOOL SAFETY.
WE KNOW THAT THE IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC IN THE NATIONAL
RECKONING WITH OUR REGION
SYSTEMS HAVE EXACERBATED A LOT
OF INEQUITY BETWEEN OUR
STUDENTS PARTICULARLY IMPACTING
YOU THE COLOR. AND ESPECIALLY
AT SEGREGATED SCHOOLS. THE
TEACHER I'M WORRIED NOT JUST
ABOUT THIS SPRING BUT ABOUT
WHAT THE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS
OF HEALING LOOK LIKE IN OUR
SCHOOLS. SB SIX NINE NINE WOULD
MAKE CLEAR THAT SCHOOL CRIME IS
A PRIORITY ON EQUAL FOOTING
WITH OTHER INDICATORS LIKE
ACADEMIC. ACHIEVEMENT AND GOOD
FOR TWENTY. THE END. ON THIS
YEAR BEEN A GOOD MODEL WHAT
THESE AND THE KIND OF THE
COOKBOOK LIKE. AND I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE MORE. IN WHICH TO
CLIMATE WITH THE SAME ATTEMPT
WHICH- I YOU TO PAY. THE SIX
NINE TWO THAT. IN OF COKE. BE A
PART OF THE CALC DASH. TECH
DIDN'T DESERVE TO CALM ABOUT.
IN TO CONVENE PLACE ARE
SUPPORTING. TO ENHANCE AND
MAINTAIN TREAT. AND A- IN BY.
FOR ALL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WILL NOW MOVE TO SUPPORT HERE
FORTY TWO OH THREE. SEEING NONE.
WILL MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SEEING NONE WE WILLGO TO OUR
TELEPHONE LINES- MADAME
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYONE
COMING UP. IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
NINE NINE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. SIX NINE NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE THREE IN Q.
IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR
OUR FIRST COMMENT THANK YOU.
BOOKLIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING- JERRY
LEYVA JESSICA FALCO ON BEHALF
OF CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU JUST ONE
MOMENT FOR NEXT TIME AND. ONE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS STILL
PROGRAM WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATE
CALLING INTO COURT SB SIX NINE
NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIGHT EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS TRINA
GONZALEZ AND HAMILTON HIGH
SCHOOL IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
NINE NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU HAVE A MODERATOR- LOOKING
FOR OPPOSITION I HAVE NO LEAD
OPPOSITION LISTED NO OPPOSITION
I SEEN FORTY TWO OH THREE LET'S
GO TO TWENTY FORTY SEEN NONE.
MATTER MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYONE ON THE LINE OR QUEUING
UP WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SIX NINE NINE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX NINE
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMON THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU MEMORIES
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE-
COMMITTEE SENATOR PAM. THANK
YOU SO VERY MUCH- CENTER EGGMAN
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD A
SCHOOL CLIMATE IS OBVIOUSLY IT
MARCHES OBVIOUSLY HAVE. IT WAS
SO OBVIOUS MAYBE THIS BILL
ALREADY BEEN DONE BETTER
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS IS IT REALLY DOES IMPACT
LEARNING INSPECTION WITH KOBE I
THINK WHAT THE ITEM OPTICALLY
HIGHLIGHT IS ACTUALLY LAST
MONTH- WASHINGTON POST REPORTED
THAT. ASIAN AMERICAN FAMILIES
WERE MUCH MORE JUST PORTION
RELUCTANT TO SEND OUR KIDS AND
FOR IN PERSON LEARNING. AND
IT'S NOT BECAUSE THEY'RE
BECAUSE THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT
THE SAFETY OF THEIR CHILDREN
OFTEN COATED- GIVEN THE REPORTS
OF HATE ATTACKS AND HATE
INCIDENTS AGAINST TI AND THE
NEED FOR SAFE SPACES FOR. ASIAN
AMERICANS- IN ALL PARTS
SIDELING COLLUDING IN SCHOOL
FOR THEIR CHILDREN. AND SO THE
SCHOOL CLIMATE YOU KNOW HAS A
HUGE IMPACT ON- DEBILITY AS
CHILDREN TO BE ABLE TO LEARN-
THERE IT DOES STANLEY'S COMFORT
AND- SO I THINK THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE MOVE THIS
BILL FORWARD- I WOULD ALSO
POINT OUT IN THE- GREAT
RECESSION ACTUALLY- FUNDING.
CUTS LEAD TO I THINK ACTUALLY.
BLACK OF FUNDING FOR THE A
CHILL THE KIDS. WHICH- WITH AND
AM PROUD TO ACTUALLY OFFER LIKE.
TO RESPOND THAT BUT IMPORTANT
WE STICK COURT SUPREME DATA
THEN ALSO USE WHAT YOU'RE
PROPOSING SURE THAT IT'S NOT
JUST ON A SHELF SOMEWHERE. SO
WITH THAT I WANT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BRAINS GO FORWARD AND
WOULD MOVE TO BUILD APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR
PAN OF ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE. SENATOR
EGGMAN WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE AND
JUST THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THIS
NIGHT JUST TO ECHO WHAT DOCTOR
PANTS OF THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT I THINK RIGHT NOW.
WITH THIS POINT WHERE TO CLICK
IN THE STATE IT LET'S JUST
LET'S USE IT. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE VERY GOOD
THANK YOU THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR PAN AMERICAN
SALUTE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB SIX NINETY
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA HI THEY
VûI OCHO ABOVE HI. THE CHOI
BOGUE. BY COURTESY. FOR TO THE
AYE DALY. GLAZER HI PLEASE. AYE
MCGUIRE. PAN AND I WILL KEEP IT
BILL- OPEN FOR A- TO VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER EGGMAN HAVE A
GOOD REST. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE
ONE BUILT EAR AND THEN IS SB
SEVEN OH FIVE FOOT BALL FROM
SENATOR HUESO SAID IN A RESERVE
YOU CAN MAKE YOUR WAY TO THE
EDUCATION. COMMITTEE IN FORTY
TWO OH THREE WE WOULD LOVE TO
SEE YOU. WHILE READING FIRST
CENTER HUESO LET'S LIFT THE
CALL CALENDAR ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR MAN CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CONSENT CALENDAR. CHAIR VOTING
ON A VICE CHAIR VOTING I PAN.
AYE PAN AYE. KANNST
CONSECTETUER HAS BEEN APPROVED
THANK YOU WELCOME SENATOR HUESO
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU ARE
READY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
FROM HER WOMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESS PRESENT SB SEVEN OH FIVE.
THIS IS A BILL THAT WOULD
REQUIRE THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO COME
UP WITH THE STRATEGIC PLAN.
INCLUDING THE DEVELOPMENT OF A
GRANT PROGRAM TO SUPPORT BY
NATIONAL WORKFORCE AND
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES. IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON CALIFORNIA
MEXICO CORPORATION HELD A
HEARING ENTITLED THE STUDENTS
WE SHARE. A DISCUSSION ON
EXPANDING EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR TRANS BORDER
STUDENTS. NOW I JUST WANT TO
PUT ALL OF THIS IN A CONTEXT.
IN THE UNITED STATES IF YOU IF
YOU MEASURE ALL THE STATES THAT
ALONG THE UNITED STATES MEXICO
BORDER AND THAT THAT IS THE
STATE'S ON THE US SIDE AND
STATES ON THE MEXICO SIDE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE THIRD
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD.
IN MANY CASES- THE- THE
INTERACTIONAL LONG BORDERS
EXTREMELY COMPLEX. WE HAVE A
LOT OF CHILDREN. OF AMERICAN
CITIZENS ACTUALLY LIVING IN
MEXICO. AND BEEN EDUCATED IN
THE US WE HAVE OTHERS THAT ARE
LIVING IN THE U. S. BEEN
EDUCATED MEXICO. WE HAVE A VERY
COMPLEX- RELATIONSHIP OF
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT THAT'S
HAPPENING ALONG THE BORDER IN A
VERY COMPLEX BORDER THAT'S
INTERNATIONAL. OF INTERNATIONAL
IMPORTANCE. IF YOU CONSIDER ALL
THE TRADE THAT HAPPENS IN
CALIFORNIA. WHAT THE ONE OF THE
BUSIEST PORT THE FOURTH.
BUSIEST PORTS IN TERMS OF-
GOODS MOVEMENT. IS A SENATOR
BORDER CROSSING. AND SO THIS
THIS COMPLETES THESE BORDER
THESE- INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS COMPETE. WITH ALL
THE PORTS IF YOU CONSIDER THE
LONG BEACH PORT DE LA PORT
THESE ARE MASSIVE OF PORTS THAT
MOVE GOODS THAT GOES PARKS
CANADA. AND IN MANY OF THOSE
GOODS GO WE ACTUALLY INTO
MEXICO AS WELL SO IF YOU
CONSIDER THE AMOUNT OF GOODS
MOVEMENT HAPPENING THE BORDER
THE AMOUNT OF BORDER CROSSINGS
WITH THE BUSIEST BORDER
CROSSING IN THE WORLD. IN MY
DISTRICT AND SENATE ZERO. AND
WE HAVE A JUST A COMPLEX.
COMMUNITY OF PEOPLE THAT COME
BACK AND FORTH EVERY SINGLE
DAY. AND THE EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAM. IS CORRECT WILL
GREATLY UNDERSERVED IN TERMS OF
THE AMOUNT OF RESOURCES THAT
APPLIED TO ADMIT EDUCATING
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE AND
PREPARING THEM FOR. THE ECONOMY
THAT THEY ARE CURRENTLY A MAJOR
PART OF. SO THIS THIS BILL IS
ASKING THAT WE START TO CREATE
A STRATEGIC PLAN TO GET BETTER
OUTCOMES AND PREPARE THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE TO ENTER FIELDS
THAT ARE GOING TO PROVIDE. THEM
NOT ONLY WITH A PERSONAL
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES AND A
BRIGHTER FUTURE FOR THEMSELVES
BUT THAT THEY CONTRIBUTE. TO
THE SKILL SET THAT THEY HAVE
WITHIN THE ENVIRONMENT THEY
WERE RAISED TO A KANEMI THAT IS
PERFECT FOR THEM TO SUCCEED.
AND SO. YOU KNOW IF YOU IF YOU
CONSIDER THAT IN BASRA
CALIFORNIA ALONG THE STATE
ACROSS THE BORDER FROM MARS
THIS IS A STATE THE BORDERS MY
DISTRICT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THEY'RE AN ESTIMATED
FIFTY THOUSAND STUDENTS IN THAT
IN THAT AREA. THE STUDENTS MAKE
ABOUT A PART OF A GROWING
POPULATION BY NATIONAL STUDENTS
ON BOTH SIDES OF THE BORDER
WHOSE EDUCATION IS DEEPLY
SHAPED BY THE BY NATIONAL
EXPERIENCES THEY SHARE. IN MY
DISTRICT WHICH ENCOMPASSES THE
WHOLE BORDER OF MEXICO. HE BY
NATIONAL LIVES OF THE STUDENTS
FROM FROM ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
OTHERS ATTENDING COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES MEANS THAT THEY
MUST CROSS THE BORDER SOMETIMES
MORE THAN ONCE A DAY. PAN AND
THIS IS IN LARGE PART HOW THEY
ARE PREPARING THEMSELVES FOR
THE FUTURE RESEARCH FROM UCSD
HAS SHOWN THAT STUDENTS WILL BY
NATIONAL EXPERIENCES REPORT
LOWER EDUCATIONAL ASPIRATIONS
THAN THOSE OF THEIR PEERS
WITHOUT BY NATIONAL EXPERIENCE
AND THERE. IN LIES IT SHOWS
THAT THESE CHILDREN ARE LESS
LIKELY TO RECEIVE ANY KIND OF
SUPPORT. ON ON GUIDING THEM TO
A GO TO COLLEGE. SO BY
REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD TO JOINTLY
BUILD A PLAN WE CAN TURN. HOW
WE CAN I'M SORRY WE CAN IN TURN
ADDRESS CHALLENGES FACED BY THE
BI NATIONAL STUDENT POPULATION
AND BUILD THE WORK FORCE
NEEDED. TO BUILD A MORE
EFFECTIVE AND EQUITABLE CROSS
BORDER ECONOMY IN DOING SO WE
NOT ONLY SUPPORT THE CHALLENGES
FACED BY THE STUDENTS BUT WE
ENSURE. THEY BECOME PRODUCTIVE
MEMBERS OF THE ECONOMY THROUGH
APPLE OPPORTUNITIES TO USE
THEIR SKILLS TO JOIN OUR WORK
FORCE AND THIS'S CLAYTON
GENTLEMAN WHAT AN AREA WHERE
CALIFORNIA'S WE CAN COMPARE TO
OTHER STATES OF THE UNION.
WHERE WE CAN STRENGTHEN THIS
AREA OF OUR SOCIETY AND IN TURN
HELP BUILD OUR ECONOMY AND
CREATE A MORE PROSPEROUS.
FOUGHT THE STATE FOR. THE OF
THE PEOPLE OF OUR STATE AND
ALSO JOINED IN AND HELPING. TO
BUILD THE ECONOMIES ACROSS THE
BOARD- AND MAY SURE THAT OF OUR
PARTNER TO THE SOUTH ALSO
SHARES IN THAT PROSPERITY. I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER HUESO I THINK
YOU HAVE A COUPLE WITNESSES AND
LEAD SUPPORT I HAVE LISTED-
PETRY CEO JIM TERRA AND DOCTOR
OLYMPIA. CORRECT CORRECT CACTUS
I AM VERY SORRY I KNOW I
PRONOUNCE IT IT IS AND BUT TO
CHECK ON THAT ARE BEAUTIFUL
THANK YOU SIR ALL RIGHT WE WILL-LET. WITNESSES DECIDE WHO'S
GOING FIRST PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY YOU EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES. I'M READY ANTICIPATED
CHECK ON. BUT OUT. AND I WILL.
PROCEED I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THE TO SHARE YOU MY VERY FIRST
SO FOR S. SEVEN OH FIVE. I HAVE
JUST WHICH THOSE ESTUDIANTES
GIGGLE BOND CREAM SPRY. TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA FIRST
YEARS DURING WHICH WE RESEARCH
BILL KERR MEXICO PARTNER. ALONG
PILOT PROJECTS ON BOTH SIDE OF
THE BALL. I'M SPEAKING TODAY
WITH YOU THIS BILL IS A URGING.
TO I'LL TAKE A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT PRICE TO THE SENATE
DID. AND SURE WITH YOU THAT LOS
SAN DIEGO IN TWO THE ABOUT HOW
KILEY TO. I IS THE EQUIVALENT
OF THE LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD AND A MAJOR DRIVER OF THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY. IT IS ALSO
THE HOME OF HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF TRANS NATIONAL U.
S. AND MEXICAN STUDENTS WHO
THIS REGION IS RELYING ON TO
FILL THE JOBS AND FUEL THE
INTEGRATION. THAT THE REGION
NEEDS TO REMAIN THIS POWER
HOUSES. BUT UNFORTUNATELY IT'S
FALLING BEHIND THE MEXICAN
ORIGIN STUDENTS ON THE US SIDE
ARE THE LEAST LIKELY OF ANY
GROUP TO COMPLETE A COLLEGE
DEGREE. AUSTIN 16% OF THESE
MEXICAN ORIGIN STUDENTS
COMPLETE A COLLEGE DEGREE
COMPARED 2406% FOR WHITE
STUDENTS AND 62% FOR ASIANS.
AND THIS IS THE MAJORITY OF THE
STUDENT POPULATION IN THE AREA.
THE CROSS THE BORDER IN TIJUANA
WE HAVE FIFTY THREE THOUSAND US
CITIZENS STUDENTS TRYING TO
MAKE THEIR WAY THROUGH THE
MEXICANS COOLING SYSTEM. BEFORE
THEY RETURNED TO THE U. S. BUT
MOST DON'T READ AND WRITE
SPANISH AND SO THEY FLOUNDER IN
SCHOOL. AND MANY ARE LEFT OUT
OF THE SYSTEM ALTOGETHER
BECAUSE OF A LACK OF SPACE AND
OFTEN THE NEED TO WORK. THE
AVERAGE COMPLETION RATE
DISCOUNT OF SCHOOLING IN BAJA
CALIFORNIA IS JUST NINTH GRADE.
THIS IS THE FUTURE WORK FORCE
FOR THE REGION AND THEY'RE NOT
BEING ADEQUATELY PREPARED. THE
REAL SHAME ABOUT THIS TOO IS
THAT THESE ARE POTENTIALLY OUR
BEST STUDENTS. OUR RESEARCH AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SHOWS THAT THEY'RE TENACIOUS
PERSISTENT AND OPTIMISTIC. THEY
WANT GOOD JOBS THEY ALSO WANT A
COLLEGE EDUCATION- THEY'RE
BILINGUAL AND MULTICULTURAL.
THERE THE NATURAL BRIDGE
BUILDERS AND SOCIAL BROKERS
THAT OUR TWO NATIONS NEED. TO
RAISE THE EDUCATIONAL LEVEL AND
BETTER PREPARE STUDENTS FOR THE
WORKFORCE WE NEED. WE NEED MANY
MORE TRAINED BILINGUAL
EDUCATORS ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
BORDER AS WELL AS WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS TO ENGAGE
THE STUDENTS. THIS BILL WILL
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT TO CREATE AND FUND
THE MECHANISMS TO DO THAT. WHAT
ARE BY NATIONAL PARTNERSHIPS WE
HAVE CREATED SOME BILINGUAL
TRANS NATIONAL CURRICULA
PREPARED SOME TRANS NATIONAL
TEACHER EDUCATORS. AND ARE
CREATING PATHWAYS TO HELP MORE
STUDENTS BECOME BILINGUAL TRANS
NATIONAL TEACHERS THEMSELVES.
BUT THE NEEDS ARE GREAT AND
EXACERBATED MANY TIMES OVER BY
THE PANDEMIC THAT IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED THE
SAME STUDENTS. THANK YOU YOU'RE
WELL OVER YOUR LIFETIME PROVIDE.
THANK YOU SURE OF THE NAME OF
THE REGION IS AT STAKE THANK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. HELLO EVERYONE
THANK YU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO GET MY HEART SUPPORT FOR SB
SEVEN OUTSIDE THE BY NATIONAL
EDUCATION AND WORKFORCE
OPPORTUNITY ACT. I'M I'M DOCTOR
OLYMPIC CARE TO COME THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY OFFICE THE BEST
ONE WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION THAT
IDENTIFIES OPPORTUNITIES TO
STRENGTHEN EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES
FOR OUR GREAT NATIONAL
STUDENTS. WE CONCUR WITH THE
FINDINGS OF DR GRANT THAT I AND
THE FIFTIETH STREET. CENTER FOR
U. S. MEXICAN STUDIES THAT
STUDENTS BY NATIONAL EXPERIENCE
A TYPE LOWER EDUCATIONAL
ASPIRATIONS TO GO TO COLLEGE.
ANOTHER LEFT LIKELY TO COMPLETE
HIGH SCHOOL IN OUR EXPERIENCE
THE ABOUT COMBAT THE RESULT OF
STUDENTS HAVING TO NAVIGATE TO
VERY DIFFERENT EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEMS. FURTHERMORE THE
DEDICATION OF THE BEAUTY
EXPERIENCES OF OUR BI NATIONAL.
STUDENT THAT STEP. WE THOUGHT
IT MAGNIFIED DURING THE GLOBAL.
AT THE WE STARTED OF COURSE. DR
GRANT THAT I WAS GONNA TALK AS
WELL AS COLLEAGUES MY HEART.
AND AT THAT TIME WE ARE DONE
FIFTY THOUSAND STUDENTS FROM
HOUSE CALLED WERE IN THE SYSTEM.
OUR COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS IN
THE TASK FORCE WE BEGAN WORRY
ABOUT OUR- BASED ON THE COURT.
I IN THE- ENGLISH ROW MAP
ESPECIALLY ONE ACTIVE OR- AND
NEED TO SCHOOL. BEGAN BY NEW
PROGRAMS THAT I. THE AFTER
POLICY. INCLUDING A BY NOT YOU.
AND THEIR AFTER KERR MANY BEAR
BY DOING. VERIFIED CODE. GLOBAL
COMPANY. THAT COME THEIR THEIR
BY NOW SELECT. FULLER
COLLABORATIVE AT. WE ARE DESIGN
COURSE THAT WRECKED THE FACT
THAT I'M A PROVIDE CREDIT HIGH
SCHOOL. ANTHONY SIDE OF THE
BORDER. THIS WILL PROVIDE MORE
UP FOR SCHOOL. AND ENCOURAGING
COMPLETION CARD BY NASH YEAR SB
SEVEN FIVE WOULD GREATLY.
EFFORTS ABOUT. TEACHER CLAMMING
AND RESOURCES IN BILL ARE TO
BACKGROUND FOR OUR NATIONAL.
THANK YOU FOR A PATERNITY TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT. FOR THIS
IMPORTANT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE WILL GO TO WE AND SO HIM
FORTY OR THREE SEEN MAN GO TO
RE TWENTY. SEEING NONE
METAMODEL WE HAVE KEY UP TO
SPEAK IN SOME OF A B. C. OF.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH JUST IN.
OF S. BEAST ZERO FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR I SEE NO LEAD
OPPOSITION SO WE'LL GO HERE TO
FORTY TWO OH THREE SEEING NO
ONE IN OPPOSITION TWENTY FORTY
SEEING NO ONE IN OPPOSITION.
META MODERATED WE HAVE ANYONE
QUEUING UP TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN OH FIVE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN ZERO
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE DO WE HAVE ANY
COMMENTS QUESTIONS SENATOR
GLAZERS. TWENTY SIX THANK YOU
TO THIS SENATOR HUESO FOR HIS
SENSITIVITY TO THESE STUDENTS
AND THEIR CROSS BORDER
EXPERIENCES AND HOW. WE COULD
HELP THEM MEET THEIR WITH THE
BEST POTENTIAL AND I'M HAPPY TO
MOVE TO BUILD THE PROPER TIME
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER SENATE
CORTESE. THE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEASURE TO SUSTAIN HONOR
WE CAN HEAR YOU THE LIGHTS NOT
STAYING ON SO IT'S HARD TO
TELL- IT AMAZES US GOOD ONE
THREE SPECIFIC QUESTION A TO BE
AUTHOR OF THANK YOU SENATOR- A
LOT OF THE TESTIMONY THAT WE
HEARD TODAY IN AND UNDERSTAND
THERE'S A LIMIT OFTEN FOR
TESTIMONY BUT WAS REALLY FOCUS
ON WHAT I HEARD IS THE FORMAL
EDUCATION. ASPECT OF THE BILL
AND I KNOW THE LANGUAGE OF THE
BILL. GOES BEYOND THAT THE
ANALYSIS- SPEAK. TO THE POLICE
IN MY COPY THERE'S A- THE
NUMERATION OF- WAYS THAT THE
STRATEGIC PLAN CAN EFFECTUATE
ITS GOALS. AND TO THOSE ARE
EXPANDING BY NATIONAL
INTERNSHIP IN WORKFORCE
TRAINING PROGRAMS WHICH IN MY
MIND DON'T NECESSARILY NEED TO
BE ROUTED THROUGH FORMAL
EDUCATIONAL CHANNELS LIKE
UNIVERSITIES ARE K. THROUGH
TWELVE OBVIOUSLY WE- WEEKS WE
HAVE SEVERAL BILLS IN THIS
SESSION. OF THE DEAL WITH.
APPRENTICESHIPS WITH APPLIED
LEARNING WITH OF WORKFORCE
TRAINING RELATIVE TO THE
TRADES- WE ALL KNOW IT THAT BY
NATIONAL CULTURAL. EXCHANGES
WHICH IS ANOTHER LINE ITEM IF
YOU WILL IN THE IN THE
STRATEGIC SIDE OF THIS BILL-
FOR A RELATIVELY COMMONPLACE
BUT- THEDEPUTY TECH SECTOR-
FOUR ONE- WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY
VERY HAPPY IN THE STATE
INCLUDING MY DISTRICT AND
SILICON VALLEY- IN. THE
HEALTHCARE IT CAN AND EVEN MY
OWN ORIGINAL LOCATION OF THE
LAW- ARE DUE IN ARE INTERESTED
IN IN DOING EXCHANGES OF LIKE
WHAT I HEAR THE BILL TALKING
ABOUT I WOULD HEAR YOU TALKING
ABOUT. I JUST WANTED TO GET ON
THE ON THE RECORD- FROM YOU AS
TO HOW MUCH OF YOUR- INTENT
WITH THE BILL IS FOCUSED IN
THAT AREA. AS OPPOSED TO YOU
KNOW THE FORMAL EDUCATIONAL
EXCHANGE OF BETWEEN
INSTITUTIONS. AND GENERALLY THE
WAY I CAN BEST ANSWER THAT IS
TO SAY THAT YOU KNOW I I'M I'M
PICKY BACK IN THIS BILL OVER.
OVER OF. SEVERAL YEARS OF
INVOLVEMENT ON THE SUBJECT NOT
ONLY BY MYSELF BUT OTHER
MEMBERS OF THIS LEGISLATURE
THAT OF A DRESS THIS IS A
CHALLENGE THAT NEEDS TO BE-
TAKEN ON. AND SO I'M NOT THE
FIRST. THE FIRST- YOU KNOW I
HAVE TO GIVE CREDIT TO OTHER
MEMBERS HAVE ALSO- STARTED A
DIALOGUE ON THIS ON A BI
NATIONAL DIALOGUE IN AND OUT DR
GUN THAT US- I THINK COMMENTS
WERE WERE VERY ON POINT IN
TERMS OF HOW. IMPORTANT THIS
BILL IS TO ADDRESSING THE NEED
AND ONE OF THE THINGS SHE
MENTIONED WAS A BI NATIONAL
DIALOGUE WITH EDUCATORS ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE BORDER. ALL ONE
NEEDS TO BE DONE. TO ADDRESS
THIS TO GET THE STATE BEHIND
THIS. AND TO DO AN ACTUAL
STRATEGIC PLAN THAT
INCORPORATES SOME OF THE
COMMENTS AND SOME OF. SOME OF
THE BEST. MINDS THAT WE HAVE IN
IN BOTH STATES. TO UNDERSTAND
THE I MEAN I MEAN SINCE WE
STARTED THIS CONVERSATION NOW
WE HAVE A LOT MORE INFORMATION
WE HAD BACK THEN. AND SOME OF
THAT WAS HERE TODAY IN THIS
HEARING. AND AS WE MOVE FORWARD
AND ACTUALLY DO A MORE FOCUSED
STUDY ON WHAT CAN BE DONE BY
BOTH STATES TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE- THE SHORTFALLS AND WHY THE
STUDENTS. ARE NOT ATTENDING
COLLEGE WHY THEY'RE NOT.
GETTING THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT SKILLS THAT THEY
NEED WHAT IS LACKING AND SO I'M
TRYING TO ENGAGE THE BEST MINDS
THAT WE HAVE ON. ON ON ON BOTH
SIDES OF STATE COME UP WITH A
STRATEGIC PLAN THAT- THAT IS
THE BEST YOU KNOW WE CAN WE CAN
COME UP WITH TO TRY TO ADDRESS
THIS AND SEE WHAT WHAT COULD BE
TWEAKED IN TERMS OF POLICY
PUBLIC POLICY OR HOW WE
ADDRESS. FUNDING OR HOW WE
ENGAGE OUR BUSINESS COMMUNITY
TO DO TO OFFER THOSE
INTERNSHIPS TO OFFER THOSE
MEDICATION OPPORTUNITIES FOR
BAJA TO STEP UP AND SAY YOU
KNOW WE DO WANT TO FOCUS ON
THIS CHALLENGED POPULATION
THEIR CHALLENGE TO US BECAUSE
THEY DON'T SPEAK FOR MANY OF
THEM ARE NOT FULLY COMPETENT IN
SPANISH AND THAT POSES
CHALLENGES FOR US HOW CAN WE
STRENGTHEN. THE DELIVERY OF
EDUCATION OUR SIDE OF THE
BORDER TO. IDENTIFIED THAT THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT POPULATION. NOT
ONLY BECAUSE- THEY'RE UNDER OUR
RESPONSIBILITY BUT THEY'RE ALSO
BY NATIONAL STUDENTS ARE
PROBABLY BE. EITHER ON THIS
SIDE OR THAT SIDE OF THE BORDER
CONTRIBUTING. TO THE SUCCESS OF
THE OF. OF BOTH OF OUR STATE
SO. I BELIEVE THAT- AND WE HAVE
GONE THROUGH CONSIDERABLE
ANALYSIS ON TRYING TO FIND OUT
WHAT WHAT CAN WE DO WHERE DO WE
START. I THINK WE WILL THE BEST
PLACE TO START IS TO HAVE A
PLAN. AND SO THIS WOULD GET US
ON ON ON A PATHWAY TO DEVELOP
THAT PLAN START TO IMPLEMENT
AND HOPEFULLY WE'LL DO THAT
SOONER BECAUSE- YOU KNOW A LOT
OF THESE KIDS FUTURES AND LIVES
ARE ARE CURRENTLY ON THE
BALANCE WITH AWAITING THOSE
RESOURCES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THROUGH THE TERROR- IN A AND I
AM SATISFIED WITH THE RESPONSE
I'M SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL AND
I'M JUST I'M JUST HOPING AS IT
GOES FORWARD- THAT. IT DOESN'T
BECOME OR THE DIRECTION DOESN'T
BECOME MYOPIC OR RECEIVED IN
THAT WAY IN TERMS OF
EDUCATIONAL EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS OF- EXCLUSIVELY UP
HERE DOMINATING THE STRATEGIC
PLAN THAT'S REALLY WHAT I'M
GETTING AT EVEN EVEN AT THE
HIGHEST PROFESSIONAL LEVELS FOR
EXAMPLE. BECAUSE MOST PEOPLE
KNOW THE CALIFORNIA STATE BAR
SANCTIONS AND RUNS CONTINUED
EDUCATION COURSES OF THE
INTERNATIONAL THE BI NATIONAL.
APPETITE FOR IN INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY. REINING IN EXCHANGE
OF INFORMATION WITH SILICON
VALLEY FOR EXAMPLE IS ENORMOUS-
THAT DOESN'T NEED TO BE RUN
THROUGH. THE LAW SCHOOL ON
WHICH- THAT I TENDED WERE WERE
THERE ANY ANY ANY ATTORNEY
TENDED TO CAN BE RUN. IT CAN BE
RUN BY- BY OR SANCTIONED. AT A
DIFFERENT LEVEL. OF BUILDING
TRADES ORGANIZATIONS IN THE
WORLD FOR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
COMMISSION. YOUR RESPECTIVE OF
ANY INVOLVEMENTFROM AN
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTION- COULD
SANCTION- APPLIED LEARNING IN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS WHICH I
SEEK COLD OUT HERE. BUT I AM
I'M JUST HOPING THAT WERE
EXPANSIVE AND NOT. AND NOT TO
EXCLUSIVE IN TERMS OF THE
PARTNERS ARE IS REALLY WHAT I'M
SAYING AND THAT THAT'S ALL I
WANTED TO SAY I WANT TO BELABOR
THE POINT YEAH NO PUN INTENDED
BUT TO- THANK YOU- THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR FOR. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADJUST MY GET MY
COMMENTS ON THE RECORD IN IT
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE BILL
FOR NINETY THREE BECAUSE OF IT.
THANK YOU SENATOR CORTESE-
SEEING NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR GLAZER SENT
AWAY SO WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU AND APPRECIATE THOSE
COMMENTS AND THE QUESTIONS AND
IF I CAN JUST FURTHER THAT. YOU
KNOW AS A SENEGAL NATIVE AND-
AND A SOUTH BAY RESIDENT MYSELF
AND BE FAMILIAR WITH THAT
COMMUNITY I CAN GIVE A REALLY
GOOD EXAMPLE OF SOMETHING. THAT
WAS JUST COMPLETELY DONE.
LOCALLY WHAT THE WHAT- THERE
WAS A RECRUITER FOR UP. SCHOOL
THAT ASKED THE QUESTION WHAT DO
WE EVER RECRUIT ATHLETES AND
STUDENTS. FROM MEXICO TO ATTEND
OUR SCHOOL BECAUSE A LOT OF
THEM ARE CITIZENS LIVING. IN
MEXICO THAT COULD COME TO OUR
SCHOOL. AND IMAGINE IF YOU
CONSIDER THAT THERE'S A FIFTY
THOUSAND. OF A POPULATION OF
FIFTY THOUSAND OTHER KIDS TO
QUALIFY TO LEARN IN AMERICA HE
SAID THIS IS A HUGE POOL FOR US
TO. DRAW TALENT FROM. THE WERE
THE FIRST SCHOOL IN SENEGAL TO
START TO RECRUIT. STUDENTS AND
ATHLETES FROM MEXICO. AND IN
FROM ONE YEAR TO THE NEXT FROM
BEING THE ONLY. SCHOOL THAT GOT
TO DO THAT OR DECIDED TO DO
THAT THEY BECAME STATE
CHAMPIONS IN FOOTBALL. AND THEY
JUST RECRUITED SOME OF THE BEST
I MEAN THEY HAD TO. THEY WANTED
TO MEXICAN SO WE'RE GONNA TAKE
THE BEST ATHLETES BRING MENTOR
PROGRAM AND THEY WERE A LOCAL
CAF CHAMPIONS AND STATE
CHAMPIONS FOR I BELIEVE IT WAS
LIKE THREE YEARS IN A ROW. THAT
THAT'S JUST TALKING ABOUT
FOOTBALL. AND THEN THE OTHER
SCHOOL STARTED TO DO IT AND
BEFORE YOU KNOW IT OTHER
SCHOOLS ALSO GOT VERY
COMPETITIVE I'M TALKING ABOUT
DOING THAT ACROSS THE BOARD IN
ALL AREAS OF EDUCATION. AND NOT
ONLY THAT IT'S NOT ONLY THAT
IT'S LOOKING UP THIS POPULATION
SAYING IF WE START A PROCESS
THE PRIVATE SECTOR THE
COMMUNITY AT LARGE WILL BECOME
MORE INFORMED THAT THIS IS A
PROBLEM THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED AND I BELIEVE THAT
MORE RESOURCES WILL COME AND
PEOPLE WILL LOOK AT. HOW TO
TAKE ON THIS CHALLENGE IT FROM
DIFFERENT WITH DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES AND APPLYING THE
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE IN OUR
STATE AND THEIR STATE WILL
DEFINITELY COME UP WITH NEW
METHODS TO PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE AND AGAIN
NEVER IT'S NEVER WAS QUESTION
THAT. YOUNG PEOPLE FROM OUR
COUNTRY GO. FOLLOW THEIR
PARENTS TO A DIFFERENT COUNTRY
I MEAN THAT SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN.
I MEAN IT WE ALL KNOW ENGLAND
SET UP SCHOOLS IN INDIA. AND
SET UP SCHOOLS AND OTHER PLACES
WHERE. THEY HAVE LARGE
POPULATIONS OF THEIR CITIZENS.
AND THEY FINANCE THEIR
EDUCATION AND- AND BENNETT WE
KNOW AMERICA DOES THAT AS WELL
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO THE BORDER
THAT'S BEEN COMPLETELY.
OVERLOOKED AND THE SAME
SITUATION EXISTS- JUST DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE WHY WE-SHOULDN'T. MAKE AN INVESTMENT
IN THE FUTURE OF WHO ARE
AMERICAN CITIZENS LIVING ABROAD
SO APPRECIATE. THIS WITH THIS
AT THIS DISCUSSION AND THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY. TO
SHARE THIS THIS PROPOSAL AND I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
SENATOR HUESO MENTAL CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ADAM
NUMBER SEVEN S. B. SEVEN OH
FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON LABOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT
LLEVA. HI THEY'VE I. OTRO ABODE
HI THE TROUBLED I'D COURTESY.
COURTESY I'D DALLY GLAZER HI
PLEASE R. I. MAGUIRE PAN HI AND
I. WILL HOLD THAT OPEN FOR US
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND DOLLY TO
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR WE
STILL HAVE A GREAT REST OF THE
DAY. ALL RIGHT I THINK MOST OF
OUR MEMBERS HAVE VOTED ON
EVERYTHING SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION THIS MORNING. HAVE A
GREAT REST OF THE DAY CENTRAL
BOTH YOU HAVE. TO HAVE ANYTHING
THAT CENTER TROUBLE PLEASE VOTE
ON. ALL RIGHT. EXCELLENT ALL
RIGHT SENATOR MCGUIRE IS BACK.
THIS ID AFTER. ALL RIGHT LET'S
OPEN THE ROLE ON THE STARTING
WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
PLEASE- I THINK WE'RE GOOD ON
THAT ONE. TO ONE WE NEED TO
OKAY LET'S OPEN THE ROLE ON
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE PLEASE
FILE NUMBER ONE SP THREE TWENTY
EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED AND
RE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE THE
CHAIR VOTING ONLINE SKEWS ME
VICE CHAIR VOTING NO. MCGUIRE
REQUIRE I OR EXCUSE ME DELHI.
DELHI NOT VOTING. ALL RIGHT
THAT BILL IS ABOUT TOP FIVE
ITEM NUMBER TWO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO SP THREE SIXTY FOUR
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HUMAN SERVICES CHAIR VOTING ON
MY VICE CHAIR VOTING I MAGUIRE.
CHOIR I BET BILLS OUT LET'S GO
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. FILE
NUMBER FIVE S. B. SIX NINE NINE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING I'D
VICE CHAIR PUTTING ALL MY-
DAILY. MCGUIRE MCGUIRE I WILL
HOLD THAT OPEN FOR SENATOR
DOLLY LET'S MOVE TO FILE ITEM.
SEVEN AND CALLED UP THE MEMBERS
PLEASE PHONE NUMBER SEVEN S. B.
SEVEN ZERO FIVE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON LABOR
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT. KELLY MCGUIRE.
ACQUIRE I WILL HOLD THAT OPEN
FOR CENTERED ALLEY THANK YOU
MEMBERS.
IT'S NOT TEST. IT WAS
LAST WEEK MY LAST ONE YES BUT
THAT'S OKAY- ARE WE GONNA GO
THROUGH ALL SET- OKAY WE JUST
NEED TO GO THROUGH FILE ITEM
FIVE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON ON
FILE AND FIVE IN THE WILL TO
NUMBER SEVEN. I LET HIM NUMBER
FIVE SP SIX NINE NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING ON
A VICE CHAIR VOTING HI. DELHI
KELLY NOW. THAT FILLS OUT THANK
YOU WERE GOING TO MOVE TO FINAL-ITEM NUMBER SEVEN. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS PHONE NUMBER
SEVEN S. B. SEVEN ZERO FIVE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
LABOR. PLUS SKID ME PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT.
CHAIR HOLDING I'D VOICE FOR
VOTING HI KELLY. TALLY NOT
VOTING VERY GOOD THAT BILL IS
ALSO WELL THANK YOU SENATOR
DOLLY. THANK YOU TO ALL OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS. IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT
TO US AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE
YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. THANK YOU AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANK YOU AGAIN
TO EVERYONE THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION IS NOW
ADJOURNED.